We need to improve tactile function
and speed if i'm gonna end this
we also need kryptonite that
was the last of your supply
then we'll have to go get some i'll start the
upgrades to your armor right away Captain Luthor
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
superman and lois episode 1 video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs obviously this is a big deal
that they're finally doing a superman series again
sort of like a successor series to smallville so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i believe just because of the way things worked
out with the big delays and the virus there are
now 16 episodes in season one there might wind up
being more than that but i think normally there'll
be like 20 episodes per season just like normal cw
shows but this is basically meant to be their new
flagship series like the biggest series that they
have you probably saw all the man of steel easter
eggs they have easter eggs for all the superman
projects going back to the old movies even easter
eggs for the flesh or cartoons like the suit that
he's wearing which is meant to be the first
version of his suit within the universe here
i know there are a lot of questions about how this
all fits in with the arrowverse and everything
they changed during crisis on infinite earth
because the character debuted on the supergirl tv
show too so i'll explain how they kind of rebooted
everything with crisis on infinite earths it'd
probably be much easier just to treat this like
a brand new version of this character like just
forget about the supergirl stuff but the episode
starts with a big montage of him narrating because
that's a big cw thing all the superheroes narrate
the intros to all their tv shows he basically
narrates his backstory sort of reintroducing
you to the character treating it like this is
the first time you've ever seen superman show up
on the cw you see krypton explode him gets sent
to earth in his pot basically all the seminal
moments of superman's life up to present day
the kents finding him then him learning about
his powers then him learning about his origin
going to metropolis meeting lois lane at the
daily planet for the first time him saving the
pt cruiser putting it down also meant to be a
reference to the action comics cover then the
birth of the twins obviously this is a big change
from before crisis because we saw baby jon kent
from the comics and he was a baby during crisis
but then after they both have twins and they're
teenagers the reason why they use crisis to
reboot that part of the character is they felt
like it would be much more interesting to do it
this way so they're basically doing smallville
only superman is the jonathan kent now so remember
all the scenes where clark would get into problems
and learn about his powers he had adventures all
over town they're going to have a version of that
on this tv show like problems for the twins to
solve because obviously now one of them we know
has powers the other one jon kemp will probably
get his powers later on the show and because
they go back to smallville for the series that's
where it's going to take place i know people are
wondering if we're going to see smallville actors
come back and cameo on the show like tom welling
could always come camo if he wants to they all
exist those characters in the arrowverse already
the smallville characters literally so them coming
back is just dependent upon them actually wanting
to come back jordan kent himself is already
doing a lot of detective work early in the
episode so it seems like he's very inquisitive
and will be searching for problems to solve
so they'll have that running storyline going on
while you have superman dealing with all these
earth-shattering problems in this new mysterious
quote-unquote Luthor stranger who seems like he's
from an alternate universe i'll explain that in
a second too big question on which version of lex
luthor is in that soup because clearly he doesn't
seem like he's from this version of earth i think
that gets into some infinite crisis easter
eggs then they finally get to present day in
the montage and he's stopping this nuclear reactor
meltdown by freezing a bunch of nearby lake water
into a giant ice cube lois lane's father general
sam lane is working with him clearly they have
some sort of partnership he doesn't seem like a
complete antagonist this is one of many twists and
reversals on superman tropes of previous movies
and tv series because pretty much every version
of this character you've seen before even going
back to the smallville tv series was a villain
for superman always out to get him this is dylan
walsh playing the character you probably recognize
him from something tv movies he's done a bunch of
stuff he's actually a pretty big actor so it's a
pretty big get for them to have him on the show
but the way they play it he's still incredibly
powerful in the government in the military
and even though he's working with superman
it doesn't mean they're super best friends it
just means they have a working relationship
and it sounds like there's going to be some drama
later on this season between them they find out
that someone's trying to sabotage all those
nuclear reactors later they reveal the stranger
reveals to superman that it was him that did it
and he was testing him to see what his skills
were like to see how good he was he was just using
the nuclear reactors because they had all the lead
shielding so that he could hide his presence until
he was ready to actually reveal himself to him
we find out that the family is currently living in
metropolis in a townhouse you get all these name
drops of the daily planet you get a sense of their
day-to-day when he walks into the house at night
and you notice the way they change it so during
the beginning of the episode all through his first
big save they have all this sweeping superman
soundtrack going on it's meant to feel like a big
superman movie very cinematic but when he walks in
the front door of their house and goes back into
clark kent mode all the music drops out it goes
dead silent and things get real real fast so this
is the whole thing with the tv show is this is
like the new spin on the superman character what
have they not done before they haven't shown you
family man superman in tv shows or movies before
so the whole idea that they try to hammer home
through the episode is the idea that he might be
a living god on earth he is the superman but he's
not a super dad you notice a bunch of easter eggs
around their house too on the chalkboard you see
it reads dr donner for richard donner director of
the first superman movie 1978 then it says siegel
and schuster the original creators of the superman
character the first twin is named jon kent who's
obviously jon kent from the comics he's talking
about being a freshman quarterback and they
had that reference during the flashbacks in the
montage when he was a baby he throws the football
so hard that it breaks the rope and they think
that he might have powers but they teased this
whole thing early on in the episode where superman
had them tested at the fortress of solitude
and the fortress told him that it was unlikely
that they would get powers that was just meant to
justify why superman felt like he should not tell
them about him being superman sort of explained
how it is they went their entire lives without
them realizing their dad was the most powerful
person on earth obviously we find out that jordan
does have powers during the episode then the other
mislead probably then some future episodes some
big moment jon kent will also manifest his powers
as well you notice in the background of his room
there's a small velcro's banner which is meant to
be a reference to the smallville tv series in the
crows football team clark played on the football
team for a little while superman makes a reference
to being the equipment manager for the smallville
high football team that's a reference to the
original superman movie 1978. his son jordan is
playing injustice 2 and he's actually fighting
against superman oh i'm playing as raiden superman
sucks they really wanted you to think during this
episode that he's going to turn into this super
edgelord superboy prime version of the character
that was one of the earliest predictions that
i made when they announced they were going to
do twins like oh one of them is going to be like
regular superboy like jon kent in the comics the
other one might break bad and be more like super
boy prime they said it the whole storyline with
him missing the phone calls from martha kent
because she's trying to tell him about what's
going on with the farm the reverse mortgages
then later she has the stroke and winds up
dying in a moment that's very similar or made
to be a reference to jonathan kent dying during
the superman movie they said at the whole conflict
with morgan edge he's going to be one of the main
antagonists during season one he's a big superman
villain from the comics too they revealed that
morgan edge is basically cleaning house he's also
busy buying up all the land in smallville too for
some special plot that he has that we'll probably
find out more about later this season but as
part of his plan he's basically gutting the daily
planet so he has clark kent fired probably because
he hates clark kent but he also wants to fire a
bunch of people just in general so like i said
because they're using him like they use jonathan
kent on the smallville tv show they had to have a
reason for him to be around the whole time so now
that he doesn't have to be a reporter during the
day when he's not doing regular superman stuff
he'll be on the farm day to day teaching them
about their powers giving them heartfelt speeches
like classic jonathan kent they make a reference
to dr fry dr fry was jonathan kent's doctor during
the original superman movie the way they cut the
transition was really cool too where he flies
into one end of the barn almost instantaneously
and then runs out the other end looking like
clark kent then when they're having her funeral
they cut it with all the footage of jonathan ken's
funeral when clark was a little kid these are all
the actors on set just hanging out too young clark
kent with the twins you also notice as they sort
of pan around town in the montage you see shops
are being boarded up the local economy is terrible
they sort of explain this later when they're
talking to lana lang's family like how everything
is basically gone to around town they have the
barbecue then alana shows up with her family
her daughter sarah obviously going to be one of
the big characters on the show probably get into
a whole bunch of adventures with the twins jordan
has a huge crush with her they sort of set up what
that love triangle is going to be like she has a
boyfriend right now they did the exact same thing
on the smallville tv show he fell in love with
lana lang but she had a boyfriend at the time so
they kind of teased that out over multiple seasons
before they eventually got together a lot of this
should feel very familiar for anybody that watched
any of the seasons from smallville they make a
couple jokes about her and clark going out when
they were in high school she was kind of like his
first love they said at the whole conflict with
her husband and their marriage problems that's a
bit of a reference to superman 3. if you remember
that movie it was a younger version of a neto tool
playing that character then she became the mother
on the small bell tv show now they're doing the
superman 3 plot on the superman tv show the easter
egg circle is now complete they set up the whole
teaser with the morgan edge storyline about trying
to quote unquote retrofit coal mines with new
clean technology that's definitely going to turn
into one of the big villain plots everything that
happened with this whole bar and storyline and
then finding out about them having powers him
being superman they telegraph this pretty well so
you all probably sense where this was going like
oh there's clearly going to be an accident in here
where they get hurt but they don't get hurt and he
has to explain why they didn't get hurt oh because
you're my sons and i'm the most powerful person
on earth they played for a big reversal though
oh no it wasn't jon it was jordan who saved him
then when lois's father comes back we learned that
the quote-unquote mysterious stranger the Luthor
that's in the special suit knows kryptonian
language and is basically taunting superman
using kryptonian they said it the whole storyline
with the reverse mortgages and the reason for why
everybody is selling their land to morgan edge
they paid that off a little bit at the end of
the episode too like oh why would morgan edge want
to buy up all these people's mortgages why would
he want all their land clearly this is going to be
something really huge they had the funny reference
to martha kent being like a local version of
superman because she was helping everyone with
their money problems or like superwoman the reason
why he laughs when she says that is because both
lana lang and lois lane have been versions of
superwoman in the classic comics but then the
twins investigate that's just sort of setting
up the idea that they're really inquisitive and
they're going to get into all kinds of trouble
on their own without superman around town like
you had meteor freaks on smallville they need to
have their own problems that they go solve while
they're learning about using jordan's powers they
find the pod it responds to jordan's dna because
he has superman's dna and it passes him one of the
kryptonian control crystals i don't recall that
we saw him give it back to superman i didn't spot
any really obvious easter eggs in the other items
that were just sitting around the basement of the
barn but if you didn't notice any from the classic
movies or from the smallville tv series just point
them out in the comments below when he comes back
they make the joke about him having super smell
oh i actually do have super smell i just don't
use it very often because we have the teenage boys
and they smell gross then the twins come running
up all pissed off and he basically narrates
his entire backstory to them i came to this
earth in that spaceship because my home planet
krypton was destroyed your grandparents found me
raised me and taught me to blend in and hide my
identity then you notice when he's lifting the
truck it's actually meant to be an easter egg for
the ken's finding him like he says oh i crashed in
that cornfield right over there it's meant to be a
reference to him as a baby from the 1978 superman
movie lifting the back of the truck up then as
the twins flip their he gets another alert using
his super sense of hearing that the stranger the
Luthor is taunting him setting a trap for him in
another nuclear reactor but he knows it's a trap
because he instantly flies in and says i know
you're here come show yourself then they intercut
their fight with the big fight at the bonfire
while they're at the bonfire though they sort of
set up the conflicts that are going on around town
like there's all these meth labs there's all
this shady stuff happening things that jordan
will probably try to solve with his powers like
oh i have abilities now maybe i can do something
to help lana lang's daughter sarah gives you this
really dark narration on her backstory like oh i
actually tried to kill myself because things got
really bad a couple years ago they just want to
show you that they have something in common sort
of set that ship up what that's going to be like
across season one like i said it'll probably be
like it was on smallville but classic beginner
mistake and big twist he goes in for the kiss
and the boyfriend comes around and clocks him and
starts that big brawl when jon shows up it's sort
of like a slow build so he'll probably become more
powerful over time and eventually we'll see jon
ken's powers manifest so until that they only seem
like they have a fractional amount of superman's
powers so you could still hurt them it would just
take a little more force the other bonus to that
too though is that while they only have a fraction
of his abilities they also have a fraction of his
weakness to kryptonite but while this is going
on more important you have this other alternate
version of lex luthor in the super suit fighting
superman just taunting him talking about how they
have history together and the planet he came from
was destroyed just like superman's planet was
destroyed and imagine my surprise when i found
out you were living here so here's what i think
is going on with this version of Luthor because
at the end of the episode you see him board
his really advanced looking spaceship talking
to an ai about upgrading his suit and finding
more kryptonite i think this is a reveal that
he's going to be a version of alexander Luthor
from infinite crisis and based on the way he was
talking about his history with superman it sounds
like the version of superman from his universe was
more like homelander more of a villain and he was
more of a hero in his home world now he's bound up
in the earth prime universe and he wants to take
down superman just because he remembers him as a
villain so what probably happened is during crisis
on infant earth his earth was destroyed like
pretty much everyone else's but then when oliver
is the specter rebooted the multiverse his earth
did not get brought back he somehow survived
crisis and then wound up in this universe so when
he came back to earth and learned that it wasn't
his earth and saw superman he got all pissed off
and now he's on this quest for revenge you know
who knows what his larger plan is going to be if
it's going to be like comic book alexander Luthor
but i think that's most of what's going on with
the character like he's a version of alexander
Luthor who was a good character like a hero
on his version of earth but he's going to
wind up being a villain in this universe
but everyone post all your theories in the
comments below do you think that jordan is
going to wind up breaking bad eventually and
going more super boy prime when do you think
that jon ken's powers are going to manifest
and what do you think is going on with this
alternate universe version of lex luthor they're
not going to do a big crossover episode this year
just because the virus delayed everything and
made it way too complicated but i think the
whole idea is grant gustin said that he did want
to do a bunch of superman crossovers so we might
see some superman flash crossover stuff in future
seasons if this video winds up doing really well
and everyone really likes the series then i'll
think about doing weekly videos for the series
otherwise i'll probably just cover big highlights
and super big moments as they happen through the
season but if you spotted any big easter eggs
during the episode that i didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the comments very
man of steel feeling version of a superman tv
series like do the smallville tv series but make
it feel like the man of steel henry cavill movie
speaking of which there'll be some more justice
league snyder cut trailers coming in the next
couple of weeks too because that movie is dropping
in march it'll be over four hours long of course
i'll be doing a bunch of videos for that too my
full wandavision episode 8 video will post this
friday just like normal there'll be a bunch of
the bonus videos i'll put links for all those
trailers in the description below but everyone
click here for my brand new Wandavision episode
8 trailer video in that post credits scene and
click here for my full wandavision episode 7 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!